welcome folks - koukin my name is Manu
bara and the pragmatic Aramco storage
my name is team so I'm Corbin and his
storage lifecycle team at Google our
session at KU Khan was about when you're
coming from a virtual world how do you
look at humanity's and storage so I
spent 20 years working on storage but
when I moved into Cuba nowadays I was
really looking for a cheat sheet
somebody could walk me through saying
password I approached storage how should
I look at how do I translate a to B so
the talk focus is more around widest
communities need storage when you need
storage for for admin clusters and also
for workload clusters then we draw
parallels between when you look at
architecture battles between how does
virtual machines approach storage versus
containers abroad stories so Jing do you
want to talk about imperative versus
declarative models sure so in
traditional way of managing to summarize
we have imperative api's so for example
if you want to create disk but you
perform that task
if you fail and you try again when it is
now complete changing the way of
managing with declarative API so
literally it means you just describe
what the system state is and the
controller will automatically reconcile
until it reach this state if anything
goes wrong it will trying to reconcile
again until it reach - this is our state
so attempt by automatically
so next we move on to comparing and
drawing parallels between the
operational states so looking at day two
operations about allocations of volumes
what are the different ways containers
allow you or kubernetes allows you to
map those volumes and some of the things
we talk about is how do you look at
dynamic provisioning versus static
provisioning we'll talk about some
details yeah sure for static
provisioning women the system need have
to create okay partition the disk and
the user will use that but a dynamic
provisioning will means we also have a
request the storage will be created on
demand so it's done dynamically instead
of
pre-allocated and those models are
really critical as you're deploying
container workloads in cloud or on Prem
because those models really did the 1
and D 2 operations differ greatly on
those parties and in the end you really
walked out with a quick cheat sheet off
and I'm coming from a planet a going to
a planet B and I'll still be living on
both sides but how do I do that
translation between the terminology
sheet state on word as a mean and
containers and how do I translate to
something that I'm already familiar with
and I can live in a much better and
translate those things macaques so thank
you for listening to a talk can we have
a booth at 2 o'clock please stop by and
feel free to ask us any questions we'll
be right here can welcome you back
tomorrow 10:00
[Music]